and yes we're gonna talk a little bit
about optimization but before that I
guess I should introduce myself
but more so the name is Jan Luca that's
how you pronounce it I'm at Microsoft in
the algorithms and they designed
solutions team just now I didn't just
join them a month and a half ago roughly
before that I was with these guys here
at the front and longshots systems and
Chris presented I think the session
before the one before me so doing sports
betting is in might avert and yes I also
do some training and teaching and free
or otherwise slides and notebooks for
today are on my github so that's link
where you can get everything will be
going through there's also link to
binder I'm using a few libraries which
you might not have installed so if you
want to use binder there's a link there
that will spin up a virtual machine for
free which we run for a few hours so you
can follow through the notebooks without
installing anything at all but we'll
talk about this when we get to the
notebooks so so the idea as I said is to
introduce you to optimization and I
personally think it's quite important
and some are underrated in machine
learning
my background hazing in maths and
computer science and as part of that you
do a lot of well I studied operations
research so you do a lot of optimization
in different types you do continuous
which is some of the stuff we'll see
today the discrete optimization you know
there's all sorts of of sub
specialization of the fields and in
machine learning very often I hope to
convince you today we do optimization or
well cycle er normally there's
optimization for us and we don't really
see that but it's useful I think to
understand what's going on under the
hood for two reasons one is that
sometimes most of the time it's fine
sometimes stuff breaks and you have no
idea why so that happened to me a few
times in well in our I have to say not
so much in in path of it
learn that I had a few issues with
packages that just randomly stopped
working and gave up results that I knew
were wrong and confirmed that with
different softest so this has happened
to be optimization problems and also I
think if you can take some algorithms
and perhaps modify them slightly to make
them fit your problem better then you
probably need to understand what's going
on under the hood so that's that's the
idea for today we're going to talk about
four things optimization in general so
what it is just to set the scene and as
I said optimization is a very broad
field so you want to get a horn in into
what's interesting to us today then
we're going to talk about linear and
convex quadratic programming with some
applications of this to machine learning
so we'll see quantile and robust
regression and we'll see if the elastic
net penalisation for linear regression
there's an example of convex quadratic
programming and finally I want to give
you so this will kind of be the
recurring theme and it's also the title
of the presentation is follow the
gradient ER normally and if you've
worked especially with neural networks
you know that stochastic gradient
descent and also simple gradient ascend
this is idea that we should follow the
grade in to minimize functions but I
want to give you maybe a better
intuition of why that's the case and why
that's so important so I kind of assume
that following the gradient is a good
idea throughout but then I'll explain to
you why that's the case so we'll start
with optimization and typically in
optimization you have a function and
we'll talk a lot about this function
it's known as the objective function
normally or in machine learning you
might call it a loss function and that's
what it looks like so it's just the
mapping you have a dimension P and it
might say real numbers it might take all
sorts of inputs but then it gives you an
output so it can be a black box or notic
and you know in completely transparent
and you can give it inputs and get the
output art now what you want out of this
is the optimal input and the optimal
impetus the Wunder minimizes or
maximizes either direction your function
and this we call the X starts whenever
you see a little star that's kind of
indicative of the optic
so it might be anything in machine
learning very often it's a loss that you
wish to minimize like the mean square
error for linear regression or something
with the light applause and you want the
best element or the best vector X that
minimizes or maximizes it so as I've
said in machine learning very very often
this we call a loss function and what
this means is that very often in machine
learning are actually doing optimization
you're solving optimization problems
even though you're calling dot fit in
sake let so for linear regressions you
might know that's a mean square error
which is a function of the regression
coefficients the beetus that you're
trying to estimate this little fat is
the estimation that's the statistician
in me so you'll see many hats throughout
and you have your x ey which are given
and all you're doing is minimizing the
difference or the squared if for the sum
of the squared differences between the
prediction which is this why I hat minus
whatever the data tells you with
logistic regression is the same you're
trying to minimize the lock loss which
looks like that with transformation of
the linear predictor by the logit
function but again it's the same idea so
you're trying to minimize a function and
this is the reason why I think if you're
doing any sort of machine learning you
probably need to understand a little bit
about how this is done and what exactly
is going on under the hood so we'll
start with parts optimization and the
guys for long shot I'm not allowed to
answer this question because you've seen
it before this used to be one of what
about interview questions and just to
give you an intuition so you have three
functions F one two and three and they
have the same image so that they all map
into the real axis so the output doesn't
really matter it's a number of sorts but
the inputs are different in one case f1
gets real input so it's any number which
we minus n plus infinity and it gets a
vector of a hundred of them as us their
input the second one is similar where
you're constraining the sum of the
inputs to be one so if
imagine they said they're basically
vectors in the Haifa sphere and the last
one accepts as input binary variable so
there are hundred binary variables
between 0 & 1 which do you think is
harder to denies and why is that so so
who thinks show me your hands pull
number 1 is the hardest of the three to
optimize okay the first one because the
problem is unconstrained what about the
second one who's in favor of segment not
very many okay what about the third one
few more yes that's the third one the
first one is actually interesting that
you say that some constrain hence it's
difficult it's actually somehow easier
to navigate this space for reasons which
we'll see in a second but yes the third
one is the difficult one and you're not
really going to talk too much about this
today and just give you a quick
intuition of why that's the case but the
third one is difficult to optimize
because there's no other way apart from
checking all possible combinations so
that's convene a total optimization
which in general if you want to just
create you know Oh framework or start
creating a framework and I'll use this
throughout for optimization problems
this is what it looks like the standard
form is normally to minimize something
you can always decide if you want to
maximize it can always minimize minus
the function that's that's the same so
you have as I said some input vector
which can be continuous or it can be
discrete and we're going to talk about a
continuous case today you have a
function I will assume here that we have
a single function that we're trying to
optimize so you don't have multiple
objectives which is also a possibility
and then there's this subject to a
number of constraints you have some of
them which might be inequalities some of
them are qualities and again note that
in a standard form you have less than or
equal to because you can always turn one
by multiplying by minus one interview so
you have your inequalities your
equalities and finally you have some
kind of box constraints around the
variables so the allowable date the
permissible values and we talked about
the inputs now about the art but your
function can be of of any kind it can be
linear it can be nonlinear as I said it
can be complete black box
it can also be explicit in the sense
that you can write down the mathematical
expression and that's what I'm going to
see him throughout the rest of today or
it can be implicit in the sense that
maybe it's the result of a simulation
and maybe it has some stochasticity
around it maybe every time you run it
the results are slightly different those
functions are incredibly hard to talk to
- cuz of course they jump around as you
call them and as you try to evaluate
them so you're not going to deal with
that today we're going to deal with
explicit functions and we're going to
see some linear in some nonlinear
functions but again in terms of convene
a total optimization and I'll show you
one example and we'll be asked for today
even though it's it's incredibly
interesting they're very hard problems
to solve in general and the reason for
that is that of course you need if you
have say your hundred binary variables
there's no way but to go through each
and every possible combination which is
two to the power of 100 which is 10 to
the power of 30 roughly possible
combinations and this takes a very very
very long time when you're faced with
these problems sometimes you're lucky
enough that there are approximate
algorithms you can use or there's
normally ways around it - you know you
can get approximate solutions it's not
the optimal solution but it's close to
the optimal solution through relaxation
again today in general though these are
the type of functions we want to
optimize there continues this nice this
particular function is particularly nice
because it's nice and smooth and you can
already see it has a nice minimum at
zero zero down there and it's as you can
imagine relatively easy to to get that
the general idea and the follow the
gradient that's in the title is that you
know if you're trying to go up we are
trying to go down you want to go in this
correction that takes you to the top and
this particular slide will come back
when we talk about constrained
optimization as well of course
continuous functions can still be tricky
to optimize this is the egg holder
function which is quite terrible it's
got a lot of peaks and troughs and as
you can imagine you know trying to find
what the V minimum of this function is
is a problem or is much more complicated
than say this function the other thing
which you can immediately see is that
whereas the previous function had a
single minimum which was the global
minimum in this case you have many as I
said peaks and troughs so this is the
other problem sometimes and we'll talk
about the conditions for that in a
second
sometimes your function will have
multiple minima or multiple Maxima
depending on we're trying to optimize
which means your algorithm can get stuck
in in local in local points local minima
for instance and you know you might
decide that this point is a minimum even
though you have something which is
negative down here so the condition that
saves it from this is convexity which
will again we'll just kind of hand
Waverley introduced now and go into more
detail later on did is that if your
function is convex and these are this is
very geometrically what the condition
looks like if you have two points and
you draw a line between them the
function is below it the same thing for
maximization and it's called concavity
and that's literally the other way
around so imagine this picture 180
degrees on its side this is the
condition that ensures that any local
minimum you find is also a global
minimum so if you do have it doesn't
necessarily mean this there's a single
one is it might be a multiple global
minima but they all achieved the same
value and and convexity again this is
quite important for this reason but this
so let's talk about the simplest
possible functions optimize which are
linear functions and this gives rise to
linear programming the ideas have been
around for a while and the originator of
this was George Danzig who started
looking into linear programs during the
Second World War and many of the
problems that you still solve through
linear programming in in operations
research come exception from this trying
to allocate resources optimally and this
optimally was particularly important as
you can imagine during the Second World
War so he invented one of the possible
solving methods for for this but before
that this is the general form so you
have your X and this X you normally
assume it can be again an integer or a
binary variable but we normally assume
it's just unconstrained it's the real
axis and when we want it to be positive
so you have a series of coefficients if
you imagine these are both vector so if
you imagine expanding this there is
something like your c1 multiplying x1
plus c2 x2 the etcetera etcetera so it's
it's a linear function it's a linear
objective function which is good because
linear functions are convex without any
particular constraints of them and then
in addition to this in addition to the
function itself you have linear
constraints and these are expressed by
this matrix this again is the standard
form you might have equalities you can
always turn an equality into an
inequality by introducing additional
variables called slack variables so this
is always a possibility now you have
three possible outcomes if you try and
solve something like this and we'll see
this in in the notebook in a second your
solution might be optimal in which case
you found the point or you found the x
star that maximizes a function it can be
infeasible because of course you might
require so your constraint might be such
that there is no single point that's
optimum and you can also be unbounded
which happens when you can keep on
growing your objective function infinite
so there is nothing to stop you from
achieving this going to be infinite
maximization or minimization graphically
this is what it looks like in of course
it's graphical so it's 2d for humans
limitation and understanding higher
dimensions than this and in this case
you have two variables and these green
triangle you see here is defined by
these three inequalities so these three
inequalities are effectively the three
straight green dashed lines you see this
is the region where you're exploring and
your objective function is this red line
as it happens and I think there's this
quite interesting if you're interested
in this it's a good exercise to see why
this isn't to convince yourself of why
this is the case the function itself
grows and you can see I've plotted a few
a few lines here so in this case we're
trying to maximize and both coefficients
are positive so you want to kind of move
towards the the top right corner up here
and as this function increases if you
imagine a line that kind of spans and
moves through that green triangle it
goes up up up up and at some point it
achieves its optimum you can actually
prove that the optimum is always
achieved in one of the corners or one of
the intersections of the planes from in
this case of the lines so this was the
idea this is the graphical solution as I
said you can do it for two variables but
more than that becomes a bit tricky and
this was also the idea of Dan six first
algorithm the simplex which just
explores all possible intersections
between the hyperplane so it starts
somewhere doesn't really matter where
and then starts visiting all of them
until the solution cannot be improved so
that's the idea as it turns out it's not
it's a very effective algorithm in
practice but it's theoretically not
polynomial time which means it might in
some specific cases take very long to
solve so there there are other
possibilities for this interior point
algorithm of Karmakar does exactly this
so it travels through this green region
till it finds
the optimal point so these are in a
sense this is all to say these types of
problems are easy to solve so you can
solve them and put in all the time you
can solve them for millions of variables
very efficiently and this is an
important point which is not always the
case for so we'll quickly go through
this and then I'll show you how to do
this using a couple of examples for you
so we'll just briefly as I said talk
about the LED or least absolute
deviations regression and you might have
seen this it's if you pretty sure you've
all done linear regression before and
you might have asked well why am i
minimizing the squared errors why am I
not minimizing the absolute errors which
it's an equally valid point of view and
in fact it was the point of view of
Laplace who lost the war against Gauss
who was in favor of the squared
residuals so this is the same problem as
your linear regression just with
residuals which are non absolute value
rather than being squared and as it
turns out you can quite nicely remove
the absolute value using a linear
program so you basically differentiate
the two cases of the residual being
positive and being negative into this
two variables U and V and this gives you
this linear program the twists that I'm
gonna put on this before I show you how
to do it is that you can also by tilting
that function tells in that absolute
value function slightly so the absolute
value function is a triangle and by
tilting it slightly using this towel you
can create quantile regression so you
can in a sense estimate the rather than
estimating the mean or the median in
this case of your response variable you
can estimate all possible quantiles of
the response so we'll see how this works
yes and SSD since we're going into this
I'll show you so this is the github repo
where you can download everything and
this binder allows you to launch that
virtual machine where you can then run
the different
so the first example I have to use just
to give you an intuition of linear
programming and bigger so I'm using a
library called CVX pi which I recommend
there are multiple options there's
Google optimization tools there's a
number of libraries both in NC n with
Python bindings so it's sealed peas the
main library that's been developed by
the coin all project and then they have
pulp which is a Python interface and
different ways of using this from Python
I'm using this CVX pi because it happens
to have support for quadratic
programming as well so it's a kind of
single library for for the entirety of
the tutorial and numpy and pandas you
probably know already so what I'm trying
to do is define what the best breakfast
is and I'll talk to you about how we do
that I've downloaded from Tesco as it
happens a number of items so in this
data frame you have different breakfasts
ish items the energy program the amount
of fat saturated fat carbs sugar fiber
protein salt per gram and then the cost
which is also in pound sterling per gram
so what I want to do is define the
optimal breakfast and in fact this is
the possibly one of the earliest users
of linear programming was defining the
best diet and again if you think in
terms of when this was all invented the
Second World War there's this of course
of operations and but we can still play
with it so I've got some items and I can
start looking at the energy content per
gram and you have almonds and cashews
with very high energy content and fruit
blueberries with fewer you can look at
the bar plot of cost per gram cashews
are very expensive per gram and milk is
very cheap at least in this country and
then you can start looking at the
trade-offs so you might be interested
then how much energy do I get per pound
and this is the idea where we go
so if you do this you see that granola
is a very cheap source of energy and
blueberries are not because they're you
know there's not much energy in
blueberries and they're very well
they're relatively expensive compared to
to the rest here what I would really
like to do in this case is I have a few
constraints so I know that I need for my
breakfast I have an allowance of 2,500
calories per day and I want a quarter of
that 625 to be spent in a sense on
breakfast and I also know that the
maximum amount of fat I should eat
according to the nutritional society's
35% of those calories and the saturated
fat is 11% and so on and so forth for
these days I got from the nutrition
society and these define what the
perfect breakfast is in a sense of
course you'll see that it this is
debatable but it's the mathematically
perfect breakfast so it's the breakfast
that according to your nutrition society
is the best one with the items I have
available that's the idea so I've got my
constraints and I'm saying you know if
you multiplied the amount so this X
represents me for a man's as you
multiply this by the energy then this
needs to be equal to 625 which is my
total energy same thing for the fat so I
have a maximum and our amount of fat I'm
willing to ingest in the morning and
same thing for saturated fat and all the
rest and I also have minimums so I have
a minimal amount of fiber I want to have
a minimum amount of protein the
important thing about this is that if
you look at the constraints they're all
linear so you're always multiplying X
which is your decision variables and
they're all positive amounts in grams of
each item by the corresponding
energy which is the energy per gram or
do you know the fat per gram etc etc so
these are all linear constraints in the
variables that I'm optimizing over this
this X and then my objective is also
linear in in this particular case I'm
trying to minimize the cost so I want
amongst all possible mathematically
perfect breakfasts I wonder one that's
cheapest and
again this is a Linux is a linear
adjectives because you again multiplying
this X which is quantities in grams
times the cost which is pond sterling
per gram so the total this CVX sum gives
you the total cost of your optimal
breakfast and in this case it's 71 pence
so the 71 pens gets you the best math
and well the mathematically perfect
breakfast and you can quite easily
extract so this solution of the problem
takes very very little time and you can
extract the the best breakfast which
happens to be a hundred and eight grams
of wheat biscuits like Weetabix forty
grams of most of almonds and that's it
so well you'll get you get half a gram
of honey as well and half a gram of
raisins but this this raises a few
interesting points the first one is that
you because this is continuous
optimization you might end up with very
small values and we'll see that this
pops up again and again so you're trying
to optimize and you're trying to in a
sense fit this as much as possible
within your constraints and you're
trying to minimize your your cost in
this case so nothing stops some very
small values from appearing in here or
values that don't really make any sense
and the other thing you can do is also
check that your problem in fact is his
solve this correctly in a sense and you
see that the energy is indeed 625
calories and these this is the breakdown
so that's that's your total cost so this
was the very first application very
first application was I have a number of
items available and I want to allocate
them really in such a way that you
minimize typically total cost subject to
the constraints the constraints are
really the important bit here because
they thin sense give you an idea of
what's halal what's what's feasible
unless this is an exactly or disc or the
feasible space amongst your solutions so
that's the first idea
now our present to you and this is all
the non continuous optimization we'll
we'll see today I'll present to you
another problem which can now be solved
again using linear programming but using
integer linear program or binary linear
program so this is now a not a
continuous optimization problem anymore
this is a binary optimization probably
can be natural optimization problem and
if you've started computer science you
might know this is known as the knapsack
problem it is again very simple and it's
again about allocating things and in a
constrained way in a sense but as it
turns out it's incredibly more
complicated to solve the idea here is
that you have different items and they
both have values and weights so you're
trying to put them into your backpack
hence the name of the problem and you're
trying to pack as much as possible with
a constraint on the weight so you have
different values and this is all your
you're trying to to do I don't really
have any data and just want to show you
how ineffective or how inefficient is
this when you try and solve it so I just
have some random normally distributed
values the interesting bit is in this
modelling I'm now declaring my variables
to be boolean so they are zeros or ones
and I have a total capacity of a hundred
so this doesn't really affect anything
but the interesting bit is in the
problem itself so the problem itself
you're trying to maximize the value and
in this case this again is a linear
combination it's your decision variables
times the value but this X now is not
fractional anymore so it's not a
continuous variable it's a zero one verb
which means yes I'm including this item
in my knapsack or not that's the binary
decision the other thing you have is the
constrain and the capacity again linear
multiplying the X by D the weights which
means summing up the weight of the items
you decided to include and then making
sure this is below the capacity if you
solve this for 50 50 items it's fine
not really a big problem it solves quite
quickly but if she starts timing it this
becomes more interesting enough time bit
before on this laptop for a hundred
thousand ten thousand hundred thousand
elements so just going up in in powers
of ten and then took you know every time
you go up this goes up by ten times and
you can already see if I take the ratio
of the times this explodes very quickly
so it's still possible to solve it even
for a hundred thousand it took roughly a
minute 60 seconds on my laptop but you
get very quickly you know the next one
up which is a million elements takes
incredibly much longer compared to this
and I wasn't able to to solve it so this
is the problem you can scale up linear
programs or continuous linear programs
almost infinitely as long as you have
enough memory and even then you can
probably solve it out of core so you can
do that very efficiently for millions
and millions of variables the problems
like this problem so you have integer
variables are suddenly much much much
more difficult to solve so this is
something to to keep in mind algorithms
are again different they all look the
same almost as just setting that
variable equal to well boolean equal to
true but it makes things much more
complicated the last thing I want to
show you about linear programming this
quantile regression and I find is is
quite beautiful example of that
so just do
remind you this is this is a trick the
trick is that you have you're trying to
minimize rather than square residual
trying to optimize or to minimize
residuals in up to the value and the way
you can do this or the way you can split
that function which is nonlinear the
absolute value function is by separating
the contributions so you want to
minimize the total error which is the
sum of the use and the sum of the V's
and this is your linear predictor
it's your X variables multiplied by the
coefficients this is what you want your
Y and effectively this part the u minus
V are the residuals for you are the
positive deviations in a sense of the
positive residuals from the on a
positive sign on the upward slope of the
absolute value and of the other side is
the negativity so that's that's the idea
and in R you can use the package
contract that does this beautifully and
in fact there's a book on quantile
regression by by the author of this
package so it's a very simple data set
will look at as this angle expenditure
data from Belgium you have income of
households under food expenditures and
this is what the scatter plot looks like
and you can immediately recognize a
couple of things if you're ready to fit
a linear regression line to this the
first problem is that our lier up here
and maybe this one and the other problem
is that this data set is not almost got
a stick so you see that even visually
you can see that the variance increases
I used to grow up in income the
variation in food expenditure increases
as well so couple problems that would
make you question a simple linear
regression so all I'm doing is defining
my model matrix and you've seen this
before if you do scikit-learn probably
you have the intercept and these are the
values from your income these are the
value food expenditures and interest
it comes now so defining the problem
itself I find that CVX buys quite quite
easy to express many problems and it
might not be the most efficient solution
in terms of of actually solving the
problem but it's incredibly easy to get
started with with me using it so you're
defining the variables we have two
regression coefficients these are the
beaters and then there's that tau which
is the parameter which comes into the
quantile regression and then you have
additional variables which are the use
under these so there's one year one set
of abused and one set of bees and there
are as many as there are observations so
suddenly I have two variables for the
coefficients and then I have two times
the number of observations in my data
set for these kind of fake variables
that I need to be able to solve the
problem and this is not at all uncommon
so very very often in optimization you
end up introducing additional variables
which are not part of your problem but
you need to solve whatever it is you're
trying to do then comes the objective
function and this is pretty much a
one-to-one translation of what you have
on this slide 12 so tau Tom times that
some of yous plus 1 minus tau times the
sum of these and as I can see that's
pretty much what you have and the
constraint is again the same they had a
nice thing about CVX PI's that you can
specify constraints even if there are
matrices and vectors you can just
multiply them so the interface is very
similar to number like you have to use
their own functions because this is
internally this keeps track of what is
the problem is convex or not so you have
to go through matte mall rather than
using NP dot for instance or the
six but apart from this business a very
similar interface so once that's done
you can set your value for tower and in
this case I want to meet in so that's
0.5 and you can solve the problem this
is the final result of the optimization
this is the sum of the absolute
residuals now you can get your
coefficients out but I think the best
representation of this is in terms of
the regression line and this is your
regression line and I've plotted the
same here with this red line being the
least square solution this is your
linear regression line as you can see
it's kind of affected by outlier and the
Green Line is the quantum well the
median in this case regression solution
now once you have the problem you can
quite easily change say that now you
want rather than the median you won the
25th percentile that's easily changed
and quick to solve by the way while
while this things about the solution I
should probably say here that this is
not the way you would actually solve the
quantile regression problem there are
much better algorithm specialized
algorithms to to do this but the
interesting bit is that it can be done
and this gives you an intuition of what
it is you're actually trying to to make
both in this case to minimize and how
you turn that mathematical equation into
no network
try to
it still doesn't like me
if you manage to run this if I download
in the file then you'll see that
changing the the line means that rather
than having the median so rather than
having a line that's right in between
the points you would estimate all the
different responses for the different
quantiles so this is one use or B slot
may be the most used regression
algorithm that's the own possibility and
this is what linear programs allow you
to do but we'll see another one and the
possibilities of convex programming in a
second before that we have a few
questions I think because it's a good
question so you might be interested
rather than in estimating so when you're
estimating say a linear model you're
trying to predict the the mean response
or the mean Y as a function of your of
your predictors and the median is a
commonly used one but in specific
instances say you're trying to predict
the the 95th percentile of latency which
is one application officing this Houston
in that case you might be directly
rather than say predicting the mean
estimating what the standard error looks
like around that and then using that to
infer what the 95th percentile assuming
a normal distribution would look like
you could directly estimate the 95th of
the 99th percentile which can be helpful
again if you're looking for the kind of
maximum latency or maximum allowed
latency so you try and predict
conditional quantiles rather than all or
median which which is one one of the
quantiles rather than the conditional
mean
it is different in the sense that so
this is this is all very much long
Bayesian and in the Bayesian setting
you're trying to estimate the entire
posterior in this case you're in a sense
trying to estimate the conditional
distribution or the the quantile the
conditional quantile directly so you're
not estimating the full thing of course
you might you know you might infer what
the distribution looks like by running
this regression problem with multiple
quantiles and in the if an infinite case
of running a regression for all possible
quantiles in which there's an infinite
number you would recover the
distribution effectively but this is
more a kind of I'm just interested in a
single number which is not a central
measure like the median of the mean but
something else convex programming
and
[Music]
exactly yes that's that's exactly the
idea so if you go back to the median
business this is exactly the ideas this
is just a trick really it's a
mathematical trick to as you say
rather than having to optimize a
function that's difficult because it
jumps suddenly you know it's it's equal
to minus X for negative and then it's
equal to X for positive values and yeah
you split it into two and consider them
as two separate cases but then sum them
back up
any other questions if not progressed to
some I find more even more interesting
self that's convex programming so now we
had we had linear linear objectives so
we had X well it's linear again in the
coefficients in this case I call X and
you can already recognize this C
transpose X is the same as we had before
so the linear program was just this part
and now I'm adding some quadratic part
and this looks a bit scary if you're not
used to matrix algebra but all this is
is effectively Q and multiplying all
possible pairwise products between your
different X's so you have all the the X
Squared's and all they say x1 times x2
the x 2 x 3 and so on and so forth and
this 1/2 serves little purpose it's it's
there is it can imagine when you
differentiate they will come back later
so you have a quadratic objective
you also have quadratic constraints if
you want and now the question is is this
as easy to solve as the linear program
because the linear programs are always
convex by definition because they're
linear so they're nice and easy but this
is now quadratic which allows you to do
more interesting stuff in particular
lancers you to do least squares they
were the original linear regression
which we'll see in a second but is it
convex always necessarily so thus being
quadratic implied being convex who is in
favor of this motion but who is not so
our quadratic functions always off if
you remember that parabola had
previously that had a single nice local
min of a local and global minimum
because of the convexity but is this
always the case of course that is one
example of a quadratic function because
that's x squared which is convex
but is this always the case that's the
question I see a few no so I think it
give us an idea of why no saddle points
yes that's that's the bane of
optimization is points where in one
direction
Gault's say has a local minimum in the
other direction it's a local maximum so
a saddle is an example of that and this
constrains what you can do so even if
you move from linear where everything
was nice and simple you moved to
quadratic suddenly you start having
problems and not all functions are as
easy to optimize as each other some of
them have multiple minima some of them a
subtle points which are not minima not
Maxima that kind of strange objects
where you might end up and not be too
happy about so we'll talk about all of
this in this section as an example if
you've used ordinary least squares this
is what it looks like is this now the
the traditional linear regression same
as before but now we have the squared
residuals and you can rewrite this quite
easily as in the same format as I had
previously so this is what it looks like
you have your coefficients and they
multiply your x transpose x is the kind
of variance covariance matrix then you
have this second linear part and the
last part is just the constant which you
can as well drop it doesn't really make
any difference interesting bit about
this is that even if you don't believe
for now that you should follow the
gradient if you do follow the gradient
and set it to zero and see what happens
you recover the master equation to
recover the solution once you take the
gradient so for beta this well first of
all notice that the two goes away
because this on both sides this guy can
pop onto the other side there's how you
get the second equation and then this is
how you get the inverse in you multiply
both sides on the left by X transpose X
let's go to the other side at inverse
and this is your traditional equation of
for your regression coefficients but
this was an aside rather than doing this
we're actually going to do regularized
linear regression so we're gonna see
rich regularization and in this case
it's again quite simple to to write down
a bit less simple to estimate so you
have your lambda which normally estimate
by cross-validation is it's just a
strength of the regularization and then
this is the sum of your coefficients
squared by the way this is one
possibility the other one is Isla su
which we'll cover during the notebook
but there's this easier to to solve
manually so what you see then is there
in your objective you get this
additional term which is just straight
out of various still in the quadratic
part of course so it comes up in the
quadratic part as well and the utility
of this especially once we get to the
example is that in normal linear
regression you're not particularly
interested in imposing any constraints
on the coefficient so your coefficients
can be positive can be negative can be
any number at all
but this doesn't need to be the case you
might want them to be positive because
you happen to know that they're right so
their intensity there are numbers that
ought to be positive or maybe they are
between some lower bound and upper bound
because again you happen to know that
that's what the range of possible values
is or you might also have some fancy
still linear or quadratic convex
quadratic constraints for instance you
might want them to be positive and you
might wonder some to be equal to one
because they represent some sort of
proportions or probability distribution
it's possible and all of this can be
encoded quite quite nicely in this
framework so what I'm using now is again
it's another data set this is the child
health and development study and this is
just to show you that you can do you can
effectively rebuild and if you're
interested in as I encourage you to go
through the notebooks as well and you
know your own time unfortunately you're
kind of even though it's an hour and a
half it's it's timely as it for for what
what you're seeing so you can
reconstruct many many algorithms just
with C the X Y and it's I think quite
informative to just play around and
change things inside see how they break
so in this case this is a data set from
the child health and development study
and all I want to do is a simple very
simple regularized linear regression on
it I'm trying to predict birth weight
based on a number of variables on the
mother and the father and some
preparation of the data but the interest
invictus is down here I'm doing my train
tests split of this common selector 20%
for the test set preparing my data and
now comes the magic so first thing I do
is define my mean squared error this is
what you expect this is my prediction x
multiplied by the regression
coefficients minus y and then take the
two norm and the 2p norm of that square
it's divided by the number of
observations this is just your vanilla
mean squared error then I also define
the elastic neck penalty and if you've
not seen this before the elastic net is
a combination of the two penalties the
rich penalty which is the squared one we
saw in the slides and a lesser penalty
which is the sum of the coefficients in
absolute
so this is the first bit up here is the
l1 penalty the lassoo penalty and second
bit here is the rich penalty of the
Tikhonov penalty which is the l2 then
all I'm doing is defining my regular ice
loss which is the mean square error plus
the elastic net and this is what I want
to minimize the really nice thing about
see the X by again is that you can
define visas functions separately and
then collect say well optimize the
regular ice loss and it will of course
call the different functions and being
able to figure out that all of this is
quadratic and convex and everything is
good and nice I also have a variable
here called fit which defines the
problem so you can rerun it for multiple
values of lambdas and I'm trying to
mimic the scikit-learn interface now so
I've defined this l1 ratios so I've got
my beaches my lambdas and I want to
minimize the loss as a function of all
of this blast the train data and then
I'm trying multiple values for the
lambda so typically rather than having
two different regularization strength
for the l1 and l2 penalties you have a
single one that then multiplies the
ratio or at least this is how Saki learn
and original paper in fact sees it so
I'm doing the same and then I'm just
solving the problem multiple times so in
a sense I'm implementing a kind of grid
search CV of sorts it's a bit simplistic
in this case I just have a train test
split but it does what expect it to do
and I'm trying a few values so these are
my data set the train 1 the test 1 this
first lock space is 10
while it's 10 values between 10 to the
minus 2 and 10 to the power of 2 so
exploring a few different values for my
lambda and
different values for my n1 ratio so you
can run this this will take a little bit
to solve because you've run in the
problem multiple times and you end up
with your metrics in your test set and a
train set and you can actually plot them
and you see something which might look
familiar
so this is R as a function of your
lambda value in log scale and the
different lines are the different values
for the l1 ratio this is the error in
the test set and this is the usual thing
of inner when lambda is quite small the
regular there's little regularization
when lambda is quite large so down here
the model tends to be a kind of
intercept only model so it's a very
simple model on this right hand side
going down through the optimal models
here in the middle to be over fitted
models here on the left hand side so you
recover pretty much what you expect
which is that line of underfitting
unfitting Goldilocks zone where we were
happy and the model is nice and
generalizable and then going back up
towards the dealer fitting area which is
in this case on on the left so you can
reproduce a lot of the stuff that you
find and again in just that don't fit in
scikit-learn quite easily in quite
nicely and again in this case all i want
to do is minimize this loss function
without any constraints but you could
decide that you want your regression
coefficients to be strictly positive or
strictly negative or any other
combination of that and this is easy to
impose in this case
any questions on this or this general
idea of minimizing well convex functions
for now we'll see now how this all
unfolds if not we'll progress to a true
meet of today which is the intuition of
why would you want to do this or why
should you follow the gradient and I
have a final application for your non
neural networks so I'll go back to this
slide and I'll spend a bit more time
talking about it so if you look at this
a bit more in detail you'll see that
there's a boy and they saying bet I can
find the top of the hill it's
blindfolded and this is important and
there are fences so there's a bit of a
silly silly drawing if you ask me but it
has a number of points if you're
blindfolded and this is a kind of
strange situation to them but if you're
blind for them you're trying to reach
the top of a hill one very good strategy
and we'll see that this is in fact how
gradient descent or ascent in this case
works very good strategy could be to
take a step to your left and see if you
go up and then a state take another step
forward and see if you go up and from
this just try to understand where it is
that the terrain is going up this will
give you information is will give you
information about the kind of direction
of the train and where it's increasing
now the additional complication which is
not often the case actually in machine
learning is that you have defenses so on
top of just walking up the this
direction are you found by taking a step
to the left and a step forward you also
need to take into account the fact there
are somehow constrains so you cannot
walk up infinitely at some point are
gonna hit the fences and you need to
stay inside that region this really for
all that sounds a bit silly is the
essence of optimization and guessing
of gradient descent or or ascent in this
case if you want more of the mats
the real reason are the so-called
courage can Tucker conditions that
effectively say three things the first
one is that you need to be within the
fence and there are sub conditions for
this which we're not going to the second
one if you don't have constrain really
means that the gradient needs to be zero
if you do have constrained then these
and this function through the Lagrangian
so this is this with the Lagrange
multipliers and then for each inequality
constraint is this the sexuality this
this is the final constraint but the
interesting bit is the second one I find
which it once you discount all your your
constraint so if you assume that in fact
there are no fences here the first one
is obvious because everything is
feasible the entire real line entire
real domain is feasible third one
doesn't apply because there are no
inequalities and the second one
simplifies to just the gradient being
equal to zero so this is the necessary
condition is that you should get to the
point where the gradient in zero and
this happens to be at the top of the
hill where you get that rent flag so
general idea is that just like the boy
you need to find a search direction so
you need to move up and you want to go
uphill or downhill if you're minimizing
and you need to find first of all a
search direction and then you need to
decide how long a step you're going to
take this is all the rest of it it's too
important so the search Direction is
this s in which to move and again
intuitively this should be the gradient
we'll see why in a bit more detail in a
second but you know once you've
determined that if you move left you go
out by this margin if you go before
would you go up by that much you know
you should be able to define ok this is
where I am in the surface and maybe I
should follow this direction which is
the direction of maximum percent in this
case and that's that's the green the
second one and this is where most
methods differ really desists you know
different
methods for optimization especially the
AC neural networks atom undergrad are
the max ovals
all that changes is how you take that
step so how big a step you take are all
smaller step you take and does it change
over time there's a lot of research
being done in how do you find this alpha
star what the optimal step size should
be but again this will come in a sec
this means you need to compute the
gradient so you need if you want of
course to minimize or maximize the
grading you need to compute it first the
traditional way of course is pen and
paper that still works it's very painful
especially if you have big likelihood
functions there are software's that help
you Mathematica does all sorts of fancy
symbolic and and simple in fact is able
to do some sort of symbolic
differentiation so you can do that but
as I said it's painful and I've done it
before I don't recommend second one is
finite differences which we'll see in a
second it works but it's not great and
the last one which is part of in a why
neural networks are now widely adopted
is automatic differentiation and we're
going to talk about that and a bit more
detail so finally differences the idea
is quite simple the idea of the of the
gradient of the derivative in this case
of just one dimension is that you do
what the boy does you change in one
direction in this case there's only one
because it's a it's a univariate you
increment by a small step that's that
little H and then there's this the
change up here is the change in your
function and down here is the change
effectively the change in your X because
is this the difference between X plus h
and X is just this H so to do this you
and you approximate your your derivative
by taking this finite difference it's a
single function call because you
probably know where you are and you just
need to take the step and see where you
end up and then compute this there's
approximation but it's not bright the
error of this is linear in the step size
so once you define what a small step
size is
then disease this is effectively the
older of Europe a better way of doing
this is rather than just taking a step
to the left its take half a step to the
left and half a step to the right and
then take a sort of difference between
the two this gives you a better
indication of what's going on in the
point where you are and probably this is
that it takes two function calls you now
need to evaluate the function in a half
a step to the to the right half a step
to the left subtract divide by the step
size but you get the good thing that the
error goes down to the approximation
error goes down to a squared order so
you gain of course more work you do more
precise it can be so this is a little
good a nice but again it's not very
practical especially when you have
millions of parameters which is what
happens in a neural network and if you
imagine having to do this in every
possible direction this means you need
to call your function a million times
every time with a different step size
for all your parameters and then if
you're doing the approximation that's on
your right hand side you need to do is
again to then compute the negative half
step size a better idea is to
differentiate automatically and a lot of
research has gone into into this the
idea is not incredibly new but the
application is especially to neural
networks so if you imagine a function
that's composed so you have an X and
then you're calling the function H on
that and you're not calling the function
G on the result and you're calling
another function f on top of this
something like this you want to compute
the derivative of this function then
this is given by the chain rule which is
really all we're doing here so the
derivative of this composition is the
derivative of F in G of G in H in H in X
so in a sense you can and hence the name
chain rule you can follow through the
chain and you see that DG which is both
in the denominator and the numerator and
D H is the same story so they don't
cancel out because they're infinitesimal
but at the end you get the final
derivative of F
the interesting bit about this is that
it doesn't really matter which order you
compute it in
if you imagine solving this and we'll
see this in a second if you imagine
writing this as a Python program you
would get a value of x and then you
would compute what the value of H is
they would take that value of H of X and
pass it on to the function G and take
the output of G and pass it on to F and
this is your final output and similarly
for the derivative the interest in bet
is that it doesn't really matter how
which order you do it in so you might
decide to compute this inner product
first which is how you would compute the
value so compute this first and then
multiply and this is called forward mode
or you could do it the other way doesn't
really matter the results should be the
same because this is all multiplied
anyway so you might decide to do this
first in Reverse compare compared to how
you would compute this if you were to to
just evaluate the function in Python and
then continue with the last one so
example to hopefully clarify this
imagine you're doing your forward mode
this is how you would compute it this is
how you would compute a function so x
and y you need to be given they are the
inputs for your function which is up
here is 3x squared plus the product of x
and y and i've calculated the
derivatives on that first method pen
paper for you so you can check that
there right the way you would do this
normally again in python is find a value
for x which is unknown to start with
find the value for y and then compute
all intermediate results you would have
to compute x squared first and I call
this a then you would take the result of
x squared multiplied by 3 which is this
first part of the sum and I call this B
then you would take x and y multiply
them together that's the second part of
the sum I call this C and then finally
your F is just B plus C as the two
components together so I've just
splitting down the function nothing more
this is internally what a computer would
do just breaking it down to the minimal
operations it can
on a CPU which is stuff like
multiplication Square and an addition
now you can take derivatives of this and
I'm taking them with respect to box and
boxes something you know it doesn't
really matter what it is it's a variable
the first two I don't really know
because of course I don't know what the
values are but then I can start
computing derivatives of the chain so if
I take the derivative of a with respect
to box this is 2x whoops this is 2x
times the derivative of X in a box and
this is just a pure application of the
chain rule nothing more same thing for 3
times a which gives you 3 times the
derivative of the internal derivative of
a would respect a box same thing as
before x times y is the same story is y
times the derivative of x in box plus x
times the derivative of Y in box and you
just keep on doing this now you can
specialize this you can say ok I
actually want the derivative of F not in
any random variable but in x and y so I
want the results up here I want least it
so you can just substitute rather than
box you have X or Y and suddenly this
becomes very easy because the derivative
of x in x is 1 derivative wine X is zero
because it's a constant and the other
way around for Y then you substitute
this is completely mechanical it's just
a bit boring to do and to redo it in
latex but this you can do on paper and
if you and I recommend you try this -
just get the intuition it's just very
dull the moment you start thinking about
it you get it wrong and this is you know
machines are great to do this so you
just substitute things as you go along
and it gets you to the right derivatives
which is great the other great thing
about this is that you can do this as
you compute so you're computing if I go
back here you're computing x squared and
you need to compute x squared anyway to
compute the value of the function so at
the end
of this procedure you get the value of
the function and you get the value of
the derivatives together now of course
we need to do this price because you
need to do it in X first and then you
need to do it in Y first so you're still
doing the work twice you in a sense
getting the functional value for free
because you're computing incrementally
but then you're also computing the
derivative in the same direction hence
the forward mode name so you're getting
to the end with function value and one
derivative for one parameter but then if
you want the other derivatives you need
to change them you need to redo it all
over again and you need to redo it all
over again and if you have a million
parameters this means you need to do it
a million times over which is a problem
so now comes the trick now let's try to
do it in Reverse which is not
immediately obvious but let's see how it
works imagine now that I'm trying to do
this in Reverse and in particular what I
have here so this is what we had
previously this is what we had with a
forward mode now let's reverse
everything and note that since
everything is reverse this is the chain
rule just being applied with the
numerators not being the denominators
but nothing else changed and you can do
that because it's multiplication so you
can turn things around more one no one
notices now rather than trying to
compute the derivative of my first
variable X with respect to box the first
thing I try to do is compute the
derivative of whatever I'm interested in
and this is now a different symbol just
so you don't confuse the two with
respect to what I actually want in the
end which is the function itself and of
course I don't know what is this because
that's what I'm trying to get it but
then I can invert all of this and if you
notice this is you know FC ba YX I'm
just inverting the order quite literally
and inverting the order of
differentiation of the of the
infinitesimals as well so rather than
you know differentiating as you would
normally do in solving the math problem
you're now doing it in Reverse so you're
asking yourself
and say this case in the last case what
changes if X changes and this is
relatively simple because if X changes
then a changes because a depends on X a
is x squared times its derivative and
then C changes because C is x times y
and it's derivative is y so you're doing
this in Reverse and you can continue
doing this and go up and up and up and
now what do you want to differentiate
over we're interested what we're really
interested in is DF DX and DF DX
sorry DF D Y DF DX which are up here so
these are the two we want and they're
kind of up here but down here so what we
want instead of this slows NJ's F really
now once you substitute this is magical
because DF DF is the same trick it's 1
then you just substitute this which is
now working backwards and suddenly you
end up with what you wanted which are
the derivatives in of F in Y and X so in
one step
you've now computed all derivatives of
all parameters by a single function call
you cannot do this at the same time as
the function call itself because the
function call goes from the inside from
the x squared so from x and y computing
x squared multiplying it by 3 taking x
times y some endure two results so this
is forward mode and if you're computing
the function value this is still how you
would do it or you can do is use this
for differentiation and compute it in
Reverse which would give you the
derivatives with respect to both
parameters at the same time now if it's
two parameters is not a big problem if
it's a million parameters then suddenly
this is much more efficient because in a
single pass you have computed a million
derivatives and there's this back
propagation
that's called reverse mode but it's
effectively what back propagation is
it's a single pass that allows you to
compute all gradients or all
relatives in in one go so back to the
original problem this was just the
differentiation now we still need to do
something with it and the something is a
method that was due to Newton he said
okay if you want to approximate a
function then one good way of doing this
is to use the Taylor expansion and just
assume that your function is the second
order approximation so that's the
function at some point this is the
starting point and then you have the
gradient times it's difference and then
you have this quadratic form and this H
is the Hessian is the matrix of all
partial second derivatives now in in all
possible variables so this is what he
started with and if you solve this and
you try to find what the optimal step
size is you find that this is the update
and in fact this solves any quadratic
problem in a single iteration in a
single step if it's quadratic and it's
convex you start anywhere assuming
you're unconstrained you compute the
Hessian which is all the second partial
derivatives you compute the gradient
which is all the first partial
derivatives you calculate your bull you
invert the Hessian multiplied by the
gradient and suddenly you are at the
optimum of course it's not that simple
and the problem is that the Hessian is a
matrix which is number of parameters
time nones of parameters so again if you
have a million parameters that might
complicate it to invert how to compute
in the first place and then you have the
gradient so this is mathematically nice
and simple if you have two parameters in
your Newton back in the day it's a bit
less simple if you have a lot of
parameters and need to compute all their
derivatives but this is the general idea
so people came up with quasi Newton
methods first the idea is that okay
maybe you know this is the optimal one
but we don't really need the optimal one
we can just multiply the gradient by
some off
by some approximation and one idea which
is the BFGS and the reduced memory BFGS
is to keep some sort of approximation of
that passion and you know to solve this
implicitly for B and then update it
every time you try and move closer and
closer to the optimum at this that's an
extrusive algorithm you try and get a
better and better approximation of the
action the other option is to just
forget about it and just say okay I
don't really care
let's just follow the gradients directly
and it will lead us to wherever the
solution is that's what come later let's
see how we do this so the first idea of
using the full Hessian was in stats at
least was reintroduced by Fisher and he
called it Fisher scoring so we give it
their full name even though it's Knuth
and methods so this is the general idea
behind maximum likelihood estimation is
exactly the same and rather than doing
linear regression undoing survival
analysis in this case just to make it a
bit fancier and what you can do is
define your negative log likelihood
function which you want to to optimize
and this is the beauty of it there's a
fantastic library that's also used by
Pytor chortle grad which will compute
the gradient and the SEM using reverse
mole differentiation for you so all I do
here is define the negative look
likelihood function and then call
gradient and Hessian and that's a this
will do the magic for you and then using
this minimize which is a function from
Sify optimize using Newton's method
really even though it's called Fisher
scoring extracting the coefficient and
if you know remember a little bit about
your traditional frequentist inference
the variance-covariance off the
estimator is given by the inverse of the
Hessian at the maximum likelihood
estimator can extract your standard
error your computer your Z values
computer p-values and can I get all the
nice things from the wall test that you
get with statistical models so this is
what it looks like in the end I've got
my intersect my stealth error might
values and my p-values and if you don't
believe that I did it correctly I redid
it in our just to see that I was right
you now you have the serve reckon in in
the survival package and as you can see
this is actually the same so all it's
doing is solving this minimization
problem well maximizing then minimizing
the minus or the negative not likely
which is maximizing at the end of the
day the likelihood function and this is
all you get slips to work which is
excellent and as I said this is in this
specific case of you having not very
many parameters you being able to
actually compute the Hessian which is in
this case only 4x4 so it's nice and easy
you can invert it that's not too
complicated to do now of course once you
move to bigger problems and you start
having millions of parameters it becomes
a bit more complicated and the trick
here is to realize that what you do very
often in machine learning is that you
don't have just any problem you have
very often problems of this kind where
you're trying to minimize not some
strange function but a function that's a
sum of many functions which all look the
same so it's some minimization and each
of these f might be your simple linear
regression model it might be a very
complicated neural networks and millions
of parameters doesn't really matter but
the only reason why it's different is
that it acts on a different piece of
your data so maybe this one is for your
first observation and then you sum it to
the same one for the second observation
so you kind of assume that they're all
independent which is the typical thing
in a regression then what happens is
that your update which was this very
simple you know take the optimal step
size whatever that might be and
multiplied it by the gradient since this
is a gradient of a sum is the sum can be
you know can push the gradient inside
so some of the Drayton's and this is
what you get so the idea behind
stochastic gradient descent is that
rather than having two computers on your
whole data set perhaps you can do this
in batches or perhaps you can do it one
by one so online or iteratively general
idea shuffle the observations for are
just to avoid any cycles and then rather
than doing this as I said with just one
massive update computing your entire
gradient for your entire function or
entire data sets just do one observation
at a time or perhaps batch them up and
is this eventually you will do the
entire data set anyway this is known as
one pass and then repeat so can I go
through your data set multiple times of
course this doesn't come with a nice
convergence properties that the full
gradient descent algorithm gives you but
you can do it on a lot of data so it's
it's actually feasible and the last
question that remains unanswered before
we see the application of this heists
how do you choose the optimal step size
there's no answer to this or there's no
easy answer to this rather as too many
interesting problems you can pick a very
large offer and your algorithm might
just shoot off because you diverge very
quickly if you take jumps which are too
high then you might just tumble down the
hill which is not good if you take very
small expect uphill this will work but
it'll take you forever to get there so
again it's that situation where you want
to be in the middle you want something
that's not too small not too large and
the problem is that this often depends
upon the data there's many many ideas as
I said behind this that have been
introduced to try and fight the problem
one is to use different step sizes
perhaps when you're at the start when
the function is still relatively flat
then you might go a bit faster so you
might take larger steps but then where
you get close to the top of your heel
then you're going to start taking small
steps more smaller and smaller steps
just approximate and actually get to to
the point where you want to be to the
maximum or you can use linear
combinations of your previous updates
this is to reduce oscillations which
sometimes happen with strange
non convex functions this is known as
momentum and it's something that's been
applied again to stochastic gradient
descent for neural networks you can
average out to resolve solver iteration
you can use different step sizes you
might decide that you know one parameter
should move quicker than another one and
this is the intuition behind behind many
of the methods like a de delta undergrad
atom the general idea is that you want
different step sizes and they're
specialized by the ways there's the
learning rate is the same same idea so
these are all possible approaches but
all I want to show you before we
conclude is how you do this and I'm
implementing now a full neural network
and well I say it's a multi-layer
perceptron it's nothing too fancy using
the MS theta of handwritten digits so if
you're not familiar with this this is
within the training set at least the
60,000 images 28 by 28 pixels of digits
and what you want to do is recognize
what digits they are so flattering in it
out
normalizing few transformations this is
what your app that looks like and then
I'm again defining very simple functions
so I have my parameters which is a
collection of my weight matrices and my
biases and then I just combined them and
the general this is the feed-forward of
the network so you take your data
multiplied by the weights at the bias
which is you can think of as an
intercept of sorts pass it through the
nonlinear activation I'm using the Tom H
function in this case you might be using
we know sigmoids or other other things
and then the very last layer undoing
this lock some ex trick to effectively
get something which is similar to a soft
max so the the predictive digit will
have the high
numbering in the output then all I'm
doing is defining the loss and my losses
this Y which is zeros and ones as you
can see here so if I'm predicting the
wrong one then I'm penalizing that
otherwise I'm unhappy and I also have a
function to print out the accuracy just
so I can see what's what's happening
another function to initialize the the
network randomly and what I do is I have
to interlace one of two hundred neurons
another one of a hundred year uns and
some values I'm deciding is this the
typical thing when your Nexus how'd you
define batch size and and the final
objective is just that the only
complication and this is made easier by
the atom implementation that's inside
Auto grad is that you need to define
your batch and in this case I'm passing
of the 60,000 observations I'm computing
the gradient for 256 of them our time
this is my batch and I have a function
that tells me which observations I
should look at in each batch from the
big matrix it's this batch illnesses and
the objective does just that you give it
the parameters you give it the iteration
number it finds which observations it
should look at it computes the loss for
that and just gives you the final I also
have my gradient computed and this is
the beautiful thing again off auto grad
you just call Brad of objective and lo
and behold you have reverse mode
differentiation of back propagation
effectively done for you so I can start
somewhere and this is the first
prediction I get which is not very great
as you would imagine so it's a you can
also compute the equivalent loss for
this and then what I can do is optimize
this using
let me show you how this works stop the
most efficient implementation is you
would imagine but it does it does the
trick there yeah so I just bring the
accuracy at the end of each batch I go
oh sorry at the end of each pass I go
through all the batches over 60,000 and
I start with a quite poor training and
test accuracy but even it's very simple
model like this one you'll see in the
second iteration gets up already much
better and accuracy last thing I will
point out while this runs is that all
you need for a demand this is perhaps
surprising is the gradient of the
objective function not the function
itself of course once you know the
direction there's no point in knowing
where you are as long as you know where
you need to move that's that's enough so
second iteration is 94% accuracy all
right in this will run for a while and
get till I think 96 or 97 percent so all
of this is effective what what is it is
doing is back propagation you can't
really see that because it's hidden away
in just a single function call but the
idea is the same as the one I presented
to you with that simple two variable
function example and this is well as I
said get you two to 96% so just to wrap
up general ideas that you know whenever
you're doing machine learning of any
kind if you're doing a linear regression
for doing a fancy or not so fancy
multi-layer perceptron you use
optimization what do you know it's or
not so it's it's behind many many many
of the things we do and I think it's
worth spending some time and really
understanding how it works mostly
because it can break and when it breaks
you want to be able to fix it but also
because sometimes it pays off to just
you know tweak an algorithm that already
exists it's very difficult to come up
with a new algorithm from scratch you
know just something that's entirely new
it's much easier to take an existing
algorithm understanding and
defy it such that it fits your problem
better and it works better and what all
you're trying to do so that was all I
had for today the materials will stay up
and of course if you have any questions
in fact before we before I leave you
I'll point you to some additional
resources if you decided you really like
optimization I have a few books convex
optimization is a classic one by the
author of cbx by Stephen Boyd
introduction to nonlinear and global
optimization is by a chap called
Hendricks who first introduced me to
this when I was studying maths and in
Portugal so he's the one well ultimately
the one responsible for this talk
numeric optimization by no stall is a
traditional textbook and I also have a
couple of online courses
CVX 101 is also by Stephen Boyd so see
some of these names over and over again
but as I said that's me for today thank
you very much for coming if you have any
questions please feel free of course or
any comments
[Applause]
final questions comments I think that
can further constraints so the the main
issue or that the way I like to think
about it is that your objective function
that the two main problems are the
objective function itself how difficult
it is if it's you know if it jumps
around or if it's non convex then then
it's tough and the domain of your
decision variables of your X if you're
trying to do integers or trying to do
binary variables then you're pretty much
screwed because you need to go through
every possible solution constraints you
can normally incorporate either with the
Lagrange multiplier trick or similar
ways but there's effectively all you
need to do is in your optimization
algorithm is constrain your step size
such that you never go outside the
feasible region yeah so in a sense of
the three components the function the
domain of the variables and the
constraints the constraints are the easy
one of the easier ones of course you
might have strange constraints which are
themselves nonlinear oh yes which would
make it more difficult but they're
normally not
oh it's not differentiable there's a
tough one why is it not differentiable
okay she cried so if you well if you try
and talk to my eyes functions which are
either very jumpy like the egg holder
there or can be notorious if ik
algorithms especially for convenient
Oriole problems there's branch and bound
algorithms you just specialized so they
might speed things up the thing is we're
know they're np-hard so they're
difficult to solve but it's still
possible to solve them up to some large
ish number of variables if the function
really is say it's the result of a
simulation or something like that and
it's very difficult than you're probably
then looking at global optimization
methods and there are many that most of
them work on heuristics really some of
those that were used when I started
doing this and you can find in the book
I quoted are things like genetic
algorithms retry and exchange things or
simulated annealing so all sorts of
heuristics that try to get you to the
point I think nowadays they the newer
developments there are in Bayesian
optimization we try and build
effectively rebuild the surface from
sampling different observations and then
maximizing or minimizing on the surface
rather than on the function itself and
sampling to reconstruct well you know
sampling where you think you have not
enough information to see what the
function looks like or what the surface
looks like so your sample there and then
you can construct a better approximation
in there the idea is this ideas is not
entirely new in the sense that quite a
few algorithms try and build local
approximations of the function for
instance the linear approximation or a
quadratic approximation is like saying
you know the heart is flat locally it's
true
of course your approximation ends at
some point which is where they start
going wrong but
[Applause]